BRIAN: THE WISCONSIN SENATE RACE
IS TIGHTENING FAST AHEAD OF
ELECTION DAY AND DEMOCRAT MA
NELLA BARNS IS CALLING IN THE
BIG GUNS.
TO CLOSE THE GAP AGAINST
JOHNSON.
HE'S SAID TO BE IN CONTACT WITH
KAMALA HARRIS AND BERNIE
SANDERS.
SENATOR, DOES THAT INTIMIDATE
YOU?
>> NOT AT ALL.
WHAT WE HAVE GOING FOR US IS THE
TRUTH.
BARNS IS A RADICAL LEFTIST.
HE SAID THE FOUNDING OF AMERICA
WAS AWFUL.
E USED THE CODE WORDS, SAYING IT
PAINS HIM THE SEE AN OVERFUNDED
POLICE BUDGET.
HE AND GOVERNOR EVERS, THEIR
GOAL IS TO REDUCE THE PRISON
POPULATION BY 50%.
AND THE PAROLE COMMISSION HAS
LET OUT 884 CRIMINALS INCLUDING
44 CHILD RAPISTS AND CRIMINALS
WHO COMMITTED OR ATTEMPTED
MURDER.
AND THEY WERE HORRIFIC MURDERS.
WE HAVE HAD A FEW WEEKS TO TELL
THE TRUTH ABOUT MANDELA BARNS.
IT SEEMS AS THOUGH THE POSITION
IS GOING AWAY FROM HIM.
HE MODIFIED THAT.
DO YOU THINK HE CHANGED?
>> NOT AT ALL.
WHAT WAS REPORTED YESTERDAY, IN
2015-2016, HE APPEARED ON
"RUSSIA TODAY."
DENOUNCING POLICE.
HE PLAYED INTO VLADIMIR PUTIN'S
HANDS.
HE'S BEING USED AS A PROPAGANDA
TOOL OF THE WAR CRIMINAL
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
BRIAN: WE HEARD THAT THE
DEMOCRATS WANT RON JOHNSON OUT.
WHY DO YOU THINK THEY ARE
TARGETING YOU?
>> I'M EXPOSING THEIR CORRUPTION
AND I WON'T BACK DOWN.
THEY HATE ME, THERE IS NO DOUBT
ABOUT IT.
I HAVE SEEN MANY ELEMENTS IN THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA, I AM POINTING
OUT HOW CORRUPT AND COMPLICIT
THE MEDIA IS AS WELL.
INCREDIBLY BIASED QUESTIONS IN
DEBATES, BUT THE BEAUTY IS I
JUST TELL THE TRUTH AND THE
TRUTH IS GETTING THROUGH.
WISCONSINITES, THEY HAVE GOOD
COMMON SENSE.
BRIAN: I WATCHED PIECES OF THE
DEBATE.
WHEN YOU SAID YOU WERE SET UP BY
THE FBI, THE CROWD LAUGHED.
WHO WAS IN THAT CROWD AND WERE
THEY FOLLOWING THE NEWS?
>> I THINK THEY LET IN A BUNCH
OF COLLEGE STUDENTS.
WE WERE BOTH SUPPOSED TO GET 50
AUDIENCE MEMBERS.
THE CROWD WAS MUCH LARGER THAN
THAT.
OUR COLLEGES TODAY AREN'T
EXACTLY TEACHING HISTORY.
THEY AREN'T TALKING ABOUT THE
RELEVANT THINGS STUDENT OUGHT TO
LEARN IN COLLEGE.
THEY ARE BEING TAUGHT LEFTIST
PROPAGANDA UNFORTUNATELY.
BRIAN: WHAT DID THE FBI DO FOR
YOU?
>> THE FBI OFFERED AN
UNSOLICITED BRIEFING IN 2020.
IT'S WHEN THEY HAD THE SCHEME TO
DOWNPLAY THE HUNTER BIDEN
ALLEGATIONS.
THEY GAVE US A BRIEFING AND
LEAKED IT 9 MONTHS LATER TO THE
MEDIA TO SMEAR ME IMPLYING I'M A
RUSSIAN TOOL.
I'M BANNED FROM RUSSIA.
IT'S MY OPPONENT WHO IS THE TOOL
OF VLADIMIR PUTIN.
BRIAN: YOU ARE LEADING IN THE
POLLS GOING INTO ELECTION DAY.
SENATOR RON JOHNSON, THANKS SO
MUCH.
>> I WILL NEED MONEY TO CONVEY